i have to perform surgery on my camera
if i don't
successfully pull these photos out from
my camera and develop them properly
all those precious memories ruined i'm
expecting the worst
we don't even know if anything's gonna
come out could have been screwed up from
the very first step
did you just take that off what am i
doing
all right nick i got a story for you man
you know i like shooting film
i was on vacation in nevada i brought my
film camera with me of course
i bring it with me everywhere every time
i travel i got some really nice
film photos of my girlfriend's family
precious memories this these are
christmas card worthy these are like oh
i remember that time
these these are some choice memories
ones you don't want to lose and here's
what happened to me
my film lever it got stuck i went into
the bathroom turned off all the lights
opened the back of the film camera i had
to cut the film strip
i accidentally cut the wrong side so now
what
yes all of those precious memories are
loose
on the right side of my camera they're
not protected
so basically i'm in a situation where
i'm gonna have to develop this color
film myself
for a while we've been talking about
like it would be really fun to do this
but we were talking about black and
white i even went bought a film camera
and took like five rolls of
precious memories word on the street
says developing black and white yourself
is pretty easy
you have to heat the liquid chemicals up
to a certain temperature and that
temperature can fluctuate about seven
degrees
when you're talking color that
temperature has to stay locked within
half a degree
if the temperature of the chemicals gets
out of that half degree
threshold your photos ruin your memories
ruin to get the temperature consistent
the best way to do that is with a
sous-vide i don't even notice who it is
apparently some cooking things
maybe we're in over our heads this video
is what you get when you take
two stinking millennials with no concept
of patience hard work
we're used to instant gratification
always we are going to
take a step into the past and see if we
can do it the way our forefathers did
i think we need a sous-vide that's like
the that's the first thing we need to
make this work
we've been driving around l.a getting
little nuggets of information from
everyone
we got to sous-vide each other we have
each other yeah we do
so i think with all of that combined we
can preserve our memories
let's throw all the stuff we need for
black and white only on the table right
all right done so i have six black and
white rolls of film that i've shot this
year
but i haven't ever developed any of my
film there are some
really intense memories in these roles
it's a bunch of pictures of just like
around
the studio all the different crew
members we got a lot of really cool
photos of like all the black rifle
coffee
dudes in their world war ii get ups i
took some pretty sentimental shots
visiting my family and i cannot wait to
see what's on them
if you don't mess up if you don't mess
this process up you'll get to see
i'm not going to mess it up your first
time doing it absolutely not
i read the pamphlet there's this company
called
sinisto and they sell a lot of
photography materials and they came up
with this really cool thing called
mono bath which is it works on any black
and white stock
and it's one chemical instead of you
know the three steps four steps
it's super easy very forgiving it's like
baby's first
film exposure pretend this is
inside the bag right what i have to do
blind
is basically getting the film out of
here
push it in there this is the hard part
because it gets caught up and then i
should be able to do this which
loads it in and once it's like this
then still in the dark bag i'll have to
put it in place this is a light blocker
so once i put that in then and only then
can you take it out of the bag you can't
let any light touch it during that whole
process
or else all your film is ruined forever
then you're good to turn it
that did not hopefully that doesn't
happen when we actually do it okay the
actual click
that's the right click
so now that it's loaded we can
go out into the light once you get your
chemicals heated to the right
temperature
you pour them in you agitate for three
minutes so it hits the film evenly
hits all the surfaces even evenly and
then
then one then one nick then what uh
this is two digital age photographers
trying to learn how they used to do it
can use it can you zip me and are you
ready
are you ready to go in i am going to
come out of this bag
with a nicely spooled roll of 35
millimeter
black and white film let's do it
all right all the light is squeezed out
i squeeze out every photon
i'm trying to find the nub on the film
canister with the pliers that i have
i got it i got it i got it my phone's
coming out dude
i'm sweaty though son i'm i'm really
afraid i'm gonna ruin this film
dude this is stressful you if you get
too nervous and sweat too much you're
gonna get your sweat all over the film
i'm guiding it in and i'm gonna feel
those ball bearings son
i'm gonna feel them fully thick part i'm
doing the shuffle right now okay
okay cutting i hope i didn't cut through
a frame
that's a memory you just you just
freaking potential a lot of memory dude
potentially
did you do it i did it it's done okay
it's in can you hear that cap
that's it it's not going anywhere are we
good
i think we're good one more truth if you
if you screwed this up your memories are
finished
yeah no they're gone i won't remember a
thing okay here we go
yes oh my god it's sweaty and sorry
you don't have to do it
ready okay
two one agitate
that's insane so the film is actually
reacting to the chemicals right now
as we speak my arms my weak arms i just
have this fear
that we did something wrong and i'm
gonna take this lid off take the film
out
i'm not gonna see anything in there five
four three two
one final agitation release get it out
of there get it out it's
burning it's burning ah your film's on
fire
take it out nick i can't get it it's too
slippery nick
nick they're on fire stop it
get it get it all right they're safe
take care don't rinse it don't break
through no memories
there's negatives it worked rinse them
with water
rinse them with water dude
dude this is awesome man this jan
dude they look great that's legit that's
so cool
that's playing spanish brothers griffin
griffin ooh there's clinton jones look
at you son
okay i'm gonna hang this up to dry we're
gonna get so much crap in the comments
for doing everything wrong and
i look forward to that because hopefully
we'll learn a lot from that
so let us know what we're doing wrong
clint do you want to try
loading one onto a spool yes i need i
need the training
i'm trusting clint with my memories here
i think we both need to experience this
before we move into the color
phase
oh dude this is sam with the mud face
mask brett with the mud face mask too
here's one of you and brett heck yeah
dude that'll be at the funeral
that'll be at my funeral for sure
[Music]
funeral strip right here son for someone
who's used to shooting on digital
and like to literally have this be your
memory card
this piece of plastic that's kind of
cool there's something
tactile and just it feels more valuable
substantial
than digital so we have successfully
developed
black and white film for the very first
time honestly guys that's just the
beginning though because next
we have to develop my color film and
that is
four times more complicated than the
black and white process so
you ready nick i'm ready to learn and
i'm ready to show you some of the new
items in the corridor digital store
we don't have a baseball bat but we got
stress based balls
we got a sweet nylon baseball jacket
actually this is one of my favorite
jackets yet
it's kind of like the bomber a little
more lightweight a little slicker
and it's got these great little snap
buttons to keep you warm
at night during one of those cold misty
nighttime games
and then also when you hit the big field
we score one for the big home team we
got our official jerseys these are for
our official baseball team
that we haven't started we haven't
actually played a game yet but we we
decided we'll start with the jerseys
get a look and the feel for the team and
then decide what type of ball we want to
really throw
also every jersey comes with a free
stress ball
we don't sell these sunglasses i'm sorry
these are just my personal shades but we
do have
some new felt b-ball hats the last time
we released the water bottle we had a
lot of complaints
they said uh sam uh my mouth is not this
big what am i supposed to i can't wrap
my lips around that well we listened
we made a smaller nalgene bottle with a
smaller
little hole up here for you to drink
your water out of you can completely
surround this with your lips
100 hydration we also have long sleeve
baseball tees and they are awesome
they're vibrant we got them in neon
yellow and other colors
really cool head on over to quarter
digital dot store right now if you want
to snag some of this
fly ass look this is a great get up
you're not going to want to miss out on
it head on over to quarter digits
or but i got to run guys i i have a big
game to catch and score some for the
winning team uh
yeah i'll see you guys out
all right so it's tomorrow after
everyone left i decided to just
go through and develop the rest of my
black and white rolls
so i did seven rolls in total they're
all dry
all my memories are literally hanging
out to dry right here for everyone to
see
we're gonna learn how to develop some
color film
all right so here's what i'm going to do
i have to perform surgery on my camera
if i if i open this right now it'll ruin
all the memories so the issue is
my camera got jammed i had to open up
the camera and
physically cut the film strip boom right
here so without looking
inside the bag i'm going to have to open
up the back of the the camera
rack the slide press the release pin
now the film will freely be able to
unwind
out from that side of the camera and
then i'll have
the film in hand and then i'll be able
to wind it on to this plastic spool
it's about the same practice as
yesterday we're just adding three extra
chemical steps
this is from cinestill and it's just a
bunch
of chemicals these are all the chemicals
you're gonna need to process
color film nick had uh the mono bath but
for color
there's a lot more steps as you guys can
see i'll look up the ratios real quick
and
we'll get it right i'm not worried
[Music]
i mix the wrong amount of water in that
what i mixed too much water this is 100
i counted it as 10.
it's cool will be good it's not that big
of a deal though they did say
your ratios need to be perfect all good
all good
[Music]
all right so i mixed all of our
chemicals together they're actually up
to temperature right now they're up to
102.
developing film is about as difficult as
d-day
i can't say that you can't put that in
did you know that uh
robert kappa who was a famous
photojournalist
landed on the first wave with the
soldiers on d-day
he shot like i think it was two or three
rolls send them back to england for
processing after the landing
did they get their chemical ratios
correct no
dude messed up exposure no they didn't
ruined all of his
roles except for like three shots and
those are those three shots that are the
famous photographs that are all blurry
are you serious oh yeah
they messed it up yeah could you imagine
screwing up
d-day photos in a way you could say that
developing those photos was harder than
d-day since
d-day actually was a success all right
nick
if i don't successfully pull these
photos out from my camera and develop
and process them properly
my girlfriend is going to be
legitimately disappointed because i took
a lot of really great photos
of her dad and those are cherished
memories memories that she doesn't have
she doesn't have good photos of her dad
chilling in a kayak
our kids are gonna look back on those
photos and be like hey that's grandpa
it's not gonna be on some hard drive
it's gonna be printed hanging on a wall
somewhere and it was taken from the
negative that i'm about to produce
right now good luck clint thanks nick
i'm going in
man i'm just my wrists are so beefy
okay man opening the back of the film
camera
the camera the back of the camera is
open i'm pulling the film
out of the camera oh i just haven't
remembered to remember something
remember that one time
that i went kayaking for the first time
the film is loose
the film is loose i heard it we're out
surgery complete
all right now it's time to load it on to
the spool film in
abort okay let's try that again
attempt number two
i have to redo it
[Music]
okay bowl
yeah i'm going to redo this again what
why
it's not going in the film is just like
really really sticky and sweaty at this
point
let's just give it a final try
and those are cherishment our kids are
gonna look back
good i'm in
all right so we're in what am i doing
did you just take that off i unscrewed
it
i didn't take the whole thing off what
am i doing dude seriously what am i
doing
now we need to start the process here
i'm gonna pour this in
so agitate continuously for the first 10
seconds then
four inversion cycles every 30 seconds
so we have to keep it in longer because
i pushed my film by four stops when i
was shooting so that means there's
barely any contrast on the film so i
have to leave it in the development
chemicals for
longer to add more contrast so we'll see
if we can just get any memories out of
this film
i'll be happy and then we do do the
blicks so you do not want to get this on
your brand new
corridor digital baseball tee start
agitating
right you're right you're right and
that's for eight minutes dude all this
all this not even knowing if any of this
is gonna work i know
do you hear that sound that was my
headphones no it's like
it's like a really chill drumming sound
[Music]
or some of those
i'm expecting the worst we don't even
know if anything's gonna come out could
have been screwed up from the very first
step
and we wouldn't know it is this the
moment of truth yep memory wind
no that worked dude i can see the frame
i can see the frames it definitely
worked
yo this is legit
well that's dark hold on that's dark
maybe i agitated too much they're very
science i
am regardless at least there's an image
there
that's pretty cool that's my cat you see
that what oh there he is oh oh something
there's one
there we go was that sun that's the sun
there's some good ones oh this is when
we went to atlanta wow
dude nice that's the one from the video
yep i need to see
there's a boat kim's father's head i
need there it is
there's the close-up of her dad he
didn't even know i was taking a photo
too wow so you know it's like the best
one
my memories every memory is on this film
role
all right so this film is very dark
which means
technically since it's a negative it's
very bright but with film you'd rather
overexpose
than under expose because you can bring
down the highlights on film really well
dude oh one was a good one dude
i can't believe we saved every memory
like there's not one memory that's
erased because of our chemical process
there's a couple shattered memories but
there's there aren't any
lost memories
[Music]
so
guys we did it we actually did it we
saved the memories
color turned out a little janky but it's
all right i'm gonna keep working on all
this if you shoot film
give this a shot i dare you it's a blast
and if you're an expert
then leave a comment on what we can do
better next time subscribe if you guys
want to see more out of the box
experiments
like this we do them from time to time
and they are a lot of
fun keep making cool stuff and i'll see
you guys later